it's quite stunning but not altogether
surprising how quickly the perspectives
on President's present and former having
classified documents uh has changed
given the recent news about Joe Biden
now as a reminder for all the people
emailing me saying David why won't you
talk about the Joe Biden classified
documents we've talked about it so many
times at this point investigate Biden
figure out what happened figure out if
there was wrongdoing but it is a totally
separate case from that of trump and it
doesn't mean you stop investigating
Trump because you're investigating Joe
Biden for a while when it was Donald
Trump who had directed staff to take
hundreds of classified documents to his
house who tried to use lawyers to
prevent giving them back who had his
lawyers say we gave them back even
though they didn't give them back and
everything that led up to the search
warrant being executed at Mar-A-Lago
during all of that time right-wingers
were saying this is a Witch Hunt this is
a paperwork issue this is a non-story
this is just something that happens and
you just deal with it and the documents
you give back and then you just move on
you don't do all of this crazy stuff
including showing up at Trump's house at
Mar-A-Lago but now all of a sudden that
it's Joe Biden being investigated for
something similar but not at all the
same thing all of a sudden now they're
talking about treason I that is not an
exaggeration in this clip I'm going to
play for you Fox News host and Perpetual
Trump brown noser Maria Bartiromo asks
James Comer congressman is this treason
and even Comer isn't ready to go that
far yet take a look we need to know now
who had access to those documents
because our national security could be
at risk Well I this is is this treason
it's it's very concerning uh we're not
going to let up I think that we've got
plenty of information to move forward uh
this would be a lot easier if the White
House would work with us but not only
are they stonewalling our investigation
you know they're they're constantly if
you watch that press conference with the
Eon Sams who's the guy they brought in
to to fight back against the
investigators which is preposterous
because this is the oversight to me
we're supposed to provide oversight so
that's our government the executive
branch uh you know it's nothing but but
slurs they need to work the American
people can see through this the media is
starting to see CNN CBS all right okay
and the music is coming up very quickly
there so up listen was Maria Bartiromo
asking whether it was treason when it
was Trump with hundreds of documents
after months of trying to keep them
right right and I want you to think
really really carefully about this
Biden having a small number of documents
Left Behind from when he was vice
president
which he didn't direct anyone to take
which his lawyers found and immediately
called the National Archives and told
them here's what we found we want to get
it back to you and fully cooperating
with an investigation that might be
treason okay on the other hand Trump
deliberately taking hundreds of
documents to his house using lawyers to
obstruct the investigation not turning
them over that is of course a Witch Hunt
or something the double standard is
breathtaking breathtaking but it is not
altogether surprising and I will again I
know people love to write in and say
David you're so biased on a lot of the I
am on the left without a doubt my views
on issues when it comes to Taxation and
the climate and education My Views are
on the left there's no doubt about it
but I make every effort not to play
these games with you because actually
unlike the fox audience which doesn't
respect Their audience and it's like my
audience is stupid we'll they'll fall
for anything we say I actually respect
you and so I don't play the debt deficit
games I don't play the gas price games
and those parties I I don't do it and
with this issue I have said there are
some relevant important differences
between the Trump and Biden classified
document situations regardless those
differences should come out in
investigations that take place into both
of them so don't play those games with
me
you might remember that a few years ago
uh the show got hacked and many
thousands of dollars were stolen we
never got it back it's a terrible
feeling it can happen to anyone but a
couple of years ago we got Aura which
really gives a significantly more peace
of mind and our sponsor Aura is the app
that protects you from scammers by
alerting you anytime your info like
email passwords social security number
are found in data breaches or also
automatically requests removal of your
info from search engines and it can
reduce spam calls Aura alerts you
quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below